one thing that scares me to death in my
life is getting to heaven and not being
what I was supposed to be you can't live
it to the next life if you're not
beating the Sun up so many of you
complain about how much time you have
you don't have time man because you
don't beat the Sun up get started early
when you're willing to take control of
your environment and put yourself
through the stressors required for
adaptation you literally can become
anything want to be happy
build a life not just a business hates
every Carmichael and this channel was
created to help you overcome the number
one challenge that is holding you back a
lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you too you've got
Michael Jordan level talent at something
so today let's live your best believe
life and learn how to get the mindset of
a champion
okay let's kick it off with real number
one live to your fullest potential with
david Goggins our purpose right now is
to continue I used to have a wash rag
and I did this and you know how to take
a shower you have a wash rag in the
cloth and you uh you're sitting there
and you just lathering up and before you
hang your rag up you want to get all the
water to come on it and you know get it
all all that other suds out of it you
want to wring it out and you want to
hang it up so my big thing is where I
live my life I want to make sure that
when I'm dead and gone that I read that
wash rag out and that Rosburg is my soul
and I also believe that we're gonna end
up one day meeting the maker if you
believe in one and I believe that maker
knows everything about you everything
about you know as I was gonna be here
and talking to you knows everything but
you also have a choice to make
give a choice to make we have choices
and the one thing that scares me to
death in my life is getting to heaven
and not being what I was supposed to be
and I believe that God has a chart and
he looks at the chart and he puts it in
front of you he get to heaven he says
hey this is what you're supposed to be
and one of my biggest fears in life was
to see that chart and not have every
block checked off hmm
you know I want to make sure that I'm
constantly pursuing whatever it is I'm
pursuing just to be the best icon just
constantly grinding myself into a fine
powder rule number two
be tough as nails with Dan Pena mr.
Carnegie was a hard bastard Vanderbilt
was a hard bastard Henry Ford the first
was a hard bastard Rockefeller was a
hard bastard Steve Jobs was a ruthless
hard bastard as Apple's CEO Cooke
regularly begins sending emails at 4:30
in the morning on Sunday he's a hard
bastard why are all these guys they
changed the world got one thing in
common take the prisoners and then we
got you a sip drinking a good kill most
people in this room I'm ashamed to say
and fast forget the sniff drink just a
good my proceeds from PayPal acquisition
were 80 180 million ba-ba-ba-ba then I
had a borrow money for rent these guys
myself included are all in if they
believe what they're doing they put all
their money at risk on which I have
several times not in recent years
SpaceX worker reveals a brutal company
motto motto helped him survive
all-nighters working for Elon Musk
notorious workaholic Elon Musk is so
tied to his office that he's been known
to sleep on the floor I slept on the
floor
Ford slept on the poor job slept on the
floor day slept on the floor success
leaves Clues you weenies
I still work 50 60 hours a week and I
haven't had at work in 35 years also if
you want to have more motivation
self-love and confidence check out my
254 series they're free the link to join
are in the description but you can
outwork anybody how bad as they are
and you want people with a like mind and
that are better than you smarter than
you more intelligent than you to get on
your bus you have to go build
self-confidence rule number three be
determined to succeed with Warren
Buffett I would I would like to tell you
of two women that each sold the business
to Berkshire Hathaway to me actually for
many many many millions of dollars both
of them started with twenty five hundred
dollars by a coincidence was the exact
same amout it was everything they had in
the world and one of them was a woman
who landed in Seattle in 1917 couldn't
speak a word of English Hanna Tague
around her neck the tag said Fort Dodge
Iowa the Red Cross got her to Fort Dodge
where she was reunited with her husband
who would come to the country a couple
years earlier and she lived in Fort
Dodge for two years and as she put it
she felt like a dummy she couldn't pick
up the language and she couldn't learn a
word and so she decided she and her
husband decided to move to Omaha so they
came to Omaha in 1919 and there she
found a small colony of Russian Jews so
she started feeling more at home and
then as her oldest daughter went to
school she would come home this daughter
Frances and she would teach her mother
the words that she learned in school
that day and this woman rose bumpkin
spent 20 years
saving money bringing first her siblings
over her mother and father fifty dollars
at a time she sold used clothing to do
it she had four children during this
period and by 1937 after 20 years
she saved $2,500 she went to Chicago and
she bought but she could have furniture
her dream had always been to open a
furniture store and this woman would
never gone to school one day in her life
with $2,500 but with the same spirit
that the people in this room had about
having a dream and working to accomplish
that dream she built a business which
she sold me in 1983 for 60 million
dollars approximately in which which did
a billion and a half dollars worth of
business last year the fourth generation
is working in that business this woman
Rose blumpkin lived while she she worked
for me until she was 103 and then I'm
not said then she retired and she died
the next year which is a lesson to all
of her churns managers
pretty mature retirement nothing you
can't tell what's going to happen but
mrs. B with her $2,500 one further fact
about her she could not read or write
and she went into a furniture business
and she didn't bring anything in unique
in furniture but she brought a
determination to succeed she knew she
could outwork anyone else she knows she
cared about her customers she worked at
very low gross margins but she built
this incredible business rule number
four beat the Sun up with Grant Cardone
grant rant of the day the one you need
to live with wake up to every day is
that right there okay beat the Sun up
folks you got to beat the Sun up if you
can't beat up the roll up of the Sun up
you're gonna get beat up in life okay
I've been doing this for a long time now
say beat that thing up that monster out
there that warms this planet that
nourishes and gives us light you can't
live it to the next life if you're not
beating the Sun up so many of you
complain about how much time you have
you don't have time man because you
don't beat the Sun up get started early
and when you get started early that
means you need to shut it down early
okay shut it down or at least so you get
sleep I was I was I was asleep last
night at nine o'clock so I could beat
the setup to market this morning and see
the world wake up with me and you'll
number five the last one before a very
special bonus clip is outwork everyone
with tom bill you Kobe Bryant one of the
greatest athletes of our time would show
up on game day and if he saw anybody
else at the gym as early as him even
though he was always at first on the
court he would end up practicing longer
than that person and I had the honor of
interviewing one of those people one
time and he said I went up in ask Kobe
Kobe
we have a game in an hour like what are
you doing out here practicing so long
and Kobe said I needed you to know that
I was willing to outwork you and in that
game they ended up winning and that
lesson stuck with that guy forever
when you're willing to put in the work
when you're willing to take control of
your environment and put yourself
through the stressors required for
adaptation you literally can become
anything and my life is proof of that
now I have a special bonus clip from
Gary Vaynerchuk and how to love what you
do that I think you're gonna enjoy but
before that it's time for the three
point landing questions let's go from
just watching the video to taking action
here we go question number one where do
you need to out work everyone number two
how can you beat the Sun up tomorrow
morning and number three where do you
need to be tough as nails that's a real
entrepreneur she or he loves it so much
they couldn't be I mean my actions have
spoken long before entrepreneurship was
cool I could I was not capable of being
a student because of my deep passion for
entrepreneurship it was baseball cards
it was baseball cards that didn't allow
me to be a good student I was incapable
of sitting in class and not dreaming
about selling bo Jackson cards it took
me over but for some reason when you're
an athlete and you're missing a bunch of
school for because you're a great
athlete or when you're Beyonce being
home school right that makes sense but
not for entrepreneurs right doesn't seem
like you're allowed to miss a ton of
school if you're an unbelievable actor
actress singer athlete missing normal
school is something that all of us in
this room and listening right now
understand you're like oh yeah that's
what happens like you're the best
quarterback in the world yeah you got a
throw with the quarterback you miss
first class you know but not for
entrepreneurs but that's who I was
if you want to learn how to develop
Spartan like discipline check out the
video right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there make a damn schedule and stick to
it ok so what's the rule with the
schedule it's not a bloody prison that's
the first thing that people do wrong